they're heading his introduction to now
this topic or this sub topic has a lot
of different names I'll give you all of
them and I'll tell you which one's my
favorite bar let you decide which one
you want to use because they all really
do refer to the same thing okay ah
straight-line motion is kind of I think
the simplest title really because it
tells you it's about things that are
roofing and they are moving in straight
lines okay strictly motion alternatively
if you want to be a little bit tacky you
can say things that go in a straight
line right up and down right there only
moving in one dimension there's only one
dimension it's updated in this case but
I suppose we could go left right if we
wanted to okay so therefore being but a
straight line is just represent one
dimension sometimes this is called
one-dimensional motion
okay the ideas that we're thinking about
in terms of motion are three particular
ideas which are all connected together
okay so what does motion actually mean
this is our third game this topic is
often called displacement velocity and
acceleration will come back to each of
those terms shortly because they're very
important to understand that is a bit of
a mouthful though okay so rather than
bring all that down and just call it
motion that's not descriptive enough
sometimes this is called kinematics okay
and you get here where the root word is
right like kinetic energy it's about
move it okay so this is about
understanding how it all fits together
okay there's one more title for it and
that is a very new south wales board of
studies their part to your question okay
because this kind of motion is what all
students who do mathematics have studied
now those are all names one thing okay
now while we're talking about tuna
motion now is a good moment to step back
and just get a bit of perspective on
this this is what encapsulate it's tuna
motion but what it flows onto for you
extension one students it is firstly
there is a very particular kind or
straight leg motion okay that when it
moves in a sort of rhythmic way okay
back and forth and back and forth we
call that simple harmonic motion simple
harmonic motion so sick while I money
SHM four-shot are lots of confusion
Sydney Morning Herald even though it's
anyway uh is is very very similar in
fact you sometimes we'll see questions
that really are simple harmonic motions
snuck into and exercise that
straight-line motion because simple
harmonic is a kind of straight-line
motion just going back and forth and
back and forth or up and down up and
down okay that's the first sign of three
inversion the next card is on call
projectile motion now
what this adds is it does add a second
dimension okay so whereas I mean
strictly speaking this we going up and
down this is a projectile it's being
projected upwards right and then coming
back down but projectile motion says
well okay what if you go and a dim not
just up and down but left to right okay
so that kind of the equations that
govern that are actually quite different
so that's why these two are extension 1
topics okay now just for the sake of
curiosity want anything else this then
feeds into the extension to motion
topics which are so fancy that they get
their own name mechanics mechanics is
kind of return a 4-3 unit work sorry for
you demotion if you like and it's got
all kinds of just like just like
extension one has sort of subsets of
motion in it mechanics talks about
resisted motion which is about when
something's moving and something's
pushing against it it talks about things
that move around in circles right so
things like a something moving like this
okay this is called the conical pendulum
because it's a pendulum type thing and
the shape that's tracing out is a cone
okay then you have a look at like bagged
circular bank tracks and other things
like that I think that spin circular
motion said tribunal force and all that
kind of thing okay so that's what comes
under this heading this is where we are
now